Graphs are useful tools for data exploration.
For example, bar graphs and pie charts are
good for categorical data; histograms, box
plots and time plots for connotative data;
and, scatter plot to examine the relationship
between a pair of quantitative variables.
Bar graph is also called a bar chart. In the
basic version of this graph, each bar represent
category and the height of the bar represents
the count or percentage of each category.
The bar graph on this slide shows the search
engine market share for different search engines.
It shows that Google has the dominant market
share in search engine market followed by Yahoo
and Bing. There are many different variants of bar
graphs. In a Pareto chart, categories are ranked
from the most popular to the least popular. The
bar graph on this previous slide is an example.
Pareto charts make it easier to spot top
categories, especially when the number of
categories are large. A bar graph can be shown
vertically or horizontally. Although horizontal
bar graphs are more common, vertical bar
graphs can sometimes be useful as well.
In stacked bar graphs, bars are stacked together,
making it easier to put multiple categories on the
same graph or show the same category over time.
Pie chart uses pie slices to represent the
percentage share of different categories. It
is similar to a bar graph, but emphasizes
each category as a part of one whole.
In other words when we used pie chart we implicit
and assumed that the category is exhaustive.
This is different from a bar
graph. The pie chart on this
slide shows the same information as
the bar graph in the previous slide.
Next, we will discuss a few basic
graph to chart quantitative data.
A histogram is a summary plot
for a single numerical variable.
It shows a distribution of the data giving some
sense on basic characteristics of the data.
Including center variability, skewness, modality,
outliers, and possibly other patterns. As an
example, this graph shows a histogram of
exam scores. We can clearly see that the
distribution is bimodal, with 1 mode between
65 and 70, and the other 1 between 80 and 85.
The distribution is centered around 70 and is
highly variable with a range between 50 and 95.
The distribution is lightly skewed to
the right, with no visible outliers.
For small data sets, histograms can be
misleading. A small changes in your data
can alter the overall pattern. For large
data sets, histograms really work well.
Even though histograms can only show
one variable at a time, side by side
histograms can be used to compare distribution of
multiple variables. When constructing histograms,
it is important to choose appropriate beam widths,
or the widths of the individual bars. If small
pinwheels is used, the graph can show too
much detail, and be hard to read. However,
using large pinwheels can lead to misleading
patterns and give the wrong real impression.
A second plot to show quantitative data is box
plot. The plot shows a five number summary of a
single variable. The five summary statistics are
shown with solid horizontal lines in the graph.
The five lines from bottom to top represent,
respectively, the minimum, first quartile,
second quartile or the median, third quartile,
and the maximum. Note that in calculating those
statistics, the outliers, which are represented
by the dots in the graph, are removed. The big
box in the plot which is between first and third
quartile contains half of the data. The inside of
the box represents the median with 50% of the
data on each side. The box plot effectively
divides the data into four quarters, and clearly
marks their boundaries. However, it is difficult
to tell the distribution shape. Also, different
tools have different implementation of the plot.
Side by side box plots are very effective in
showing differences in a quantitative variable,
across factor levels. The graph shows side
by side the lease prices of real estate
properties with and without a parking garage. It
is difficult to establish distinguishing shapes of
the lease prices. The graph shows unequally that
properties with parking garage are more expensive.
In addition, we can also easily grab a few
useful summary statistics from the graphs.
Time plot can be used when there is
a meaningful sequence such as time.
This graph shows a Google trend for the search
term gains since 2004, the graph shows a
declining trend from 2004 to 2016. In addition,
there is a clear early pattern in the data.
The number of searches peaks in January
and generally bottoms out in the Summer.
In the time plot, time should always go
on the horizontal axis. We describe time
series by looking for an overall pattern and
for striking deviations from that pattern.
A trend is a rise or fall that proceeds over
time. These spikes spot irregularities. A pattern
that repeats itself at regular intervals
at a time is called seasonal variation.
A scatter plot shows the relationship
between two unrelated variables.
This scatter plot shows the relationship
between Old Faithful geyser eruption duration,
and we can hide between eruptions. They're
appears to be a nearly linear relationship
between the two as illustrated in the graph. In
addition, there are two linear groups of data.
Data points in the bottom left have shorter
eruption durations, and short waiting times,
while the data points on the top right have
long erupting durations and long waiting times.
Since erupting time and waiting times between
eruptions tend to move together, the relationship
appears to be positive. Typically, the exploratory
or independent variable is plotted on the x-axis.
And response or dependent variable is plotted
on the y-axis. Each pair of data appear as
a point in plot. A relationship can be either
positive or negative. In a positive association,
high values of one variable tend to occur
together with high values of the other variable.
This is the case for Old Faithful data
shown before. In a negative association,
high values of one variable tend to occur
together with low values of the other variable.
The relationship between two variables may not be
linear. The Old Faithful for data shows a nearly
linear relationship. As we mentioned before,
this relationship appears to be positive,
there are so many other possibilities as shown
here. The relationship can be linear or nonlinear.
Relationship can take many different
forms. It can also be the case that no
visible pattern appears in the scatter plot, in
which case we say that there is no relationship.
Another important idea is strength of
relationship. The strength of a relationship
between the two variables can be seen by how
much variation or scatter there is around the
main form. With a strong relationship, you can
get a pretty good estimate of why if you know
the value of x. With a weak relationship, for any
x value, you might get a wide range of y values.